European Union ministers responsible for
energy policy have been unable to agree
on new rules to make the use of biofuels
me you've more sustainable and so help
cut greenhouse gas emissions but they
were able to narrow down some of the
sticking points also called indirect
land-use change unfortunately we have
had quite an exotic coalition of those
who are very ambitious in this respect
and those who not so ambitious and
therefore we did not reach a political
agreement but I think it is also
important to stress that we had a good
discussion and areas of concern were
identified and possible solutions also
where we are discussed in direct
land-use change occurs when farmland is
used to produce biofuels leading to food
or feed being grown in other areas like
forests which results in more carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere the aim of the
proposals was to minimize the
environmental impact of indirect land
use and encourage more advanced biofuels
onto the market The ministers also
endorsed a report on progress made
toward completing Europe's internal
energy market by next year's target days
it addresses aspects like the
development of energy infrastructure
ensuring investments energy efficiency
the price
a second report on the external
dimension of EU energy policy was also
rubber-stamped it covers developments in
the global energy landscape in recent
years progress made in EU policies in
this domain and looks and ways to
strengthen them